what's up guys welcome to another  episode of challenge confidences today  we'll try out this cricket bats leave  your ideas and comments in the comment  section below  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  we can be an artist right  this is my way  [Music]  [Applause]  let's try playing with a cricket bat  [Music]  how did you miss it all right  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  that's a scary shot  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  about  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  yeah okay we're gonna play a game of  table tennis cricket hey yams is not  running do I get a point for hitting  your shoes  [Music]  I did it one time  Oh  [Music]  I think I broke it yeah  [Music]  I think I was the winner of table tennis  cricket I don't think so yeah I was  clear you got Billy in the selfie booth  if you want sir